oh you see that sign that says there
then Mitchell the wall is undefeated you
are at the wall now do you know what the
wall do you know do you know what the
wall is no please tell me Bill can you
explain to the wall please
yeah the wall is basically the part
where I would say roughly around age
when a woman reaches age 30
. so looks 28 is about to start yeah
yeah it's about the start of it but yeah
but I think 30 is a typical Benchmark
and that's when her looks start to go
downhill her ability to attract men or
the same standard of men that she did
when she was in her prime which is
usually sort of late teens to mid-20s
starts to shrink and at that point her
dating pool obviously starts to shrink
as well
and really the goal for a lot of women
is to bag the guy
the she wants when she's in her prime
so I would say that at the age of 28
you're pretty much at that upper limit
towards the end of your best period to
be able to get the guy that you want
because what happens with a lot of women
right is during their Prime they'll have
a certain standard of guy and that's
what they're used to once they hit the
wall they still because you know it's
very hard for them to go down once
they've had a guy that meets a certain
type of criteria right so they end up in
this Perpetual cycle once they've hit
the wall where they still have these
high standards but they can't get that
guy anymore so yeah the aim of the game
is really to try and bag that guy and
commitment long-term commitment from
that guy before they hit the wall so I
think what what what this guy is
basically saying is that
you haven't really got much time and do
you really want to be using the
the latter stages of your Prime on
basically a long shot yeah I'll be
willing that so
um I'm just have some stuff that I've
written about the wall our primary
agency is our sexuality and how good we
look smv is a desirability to the
opposite sex 18 we
between the the wall is between the ages
of 18 and 28 or our primary agencies
between the ages of 18 and 28 when we
live to be 90. men between the ages of
20 and 70 rate 22 23 and 24 year olds as
the most attractive it's not an age but
a mindset it is the subconscious
acknowledgment that she cannot compete
in the same way she did when she was
younger
yeah so the reason I wanted to explain
it to you because I want you to
understand that if you are 28 and you're
without you you don't have any children
and I'm trying to make you understand
right now that makes you high over here
you know we are respecting that you
don't have any children so remember what
we said we treat you as a virgin so if a
woman hasn't got any children we don't
know body count she's good to go
um for you to be to waste the next year
or two years and push you potentially to
29.30 for a guy that lives in the USA
when you already know geriatric
pregnancy starts and this whole thing
about about
um about freezing the eggs and IVF I
know people have done IVF have spent
over 50 Grand in IVF and they still
didn't work
um I have family members that spent a
lot of money and it didn't work in the
end God had to you know I mean you could
have to bust them if you you're not a
Kardashian so you won't be able to just
freeze your eggs so a lot of the options
that women think they have they're not
reserved for them they're reserved for
for people that have a lot of money that
can do these things on the top on top of
that these things don't guarantee any
results so I think
for you to be speaking to someone
potentially that would and stop you from
interacting with anyone else and then in
America I just I just I just unless a
man is telling you and he's literally
putting money into your account and
saying I'm setting up a life for you to
come I I suggest you start looking for
different options okay I've been real
with you yeah because because because if
I was your brother there's no way I'm
gonna be like so what you're holding up
for this guy over there no my sister
this is what we need to do and I don't
want to see you getting 30 30 and then
you're out in we are Festival looking
for man yeah to get me I don't I don't
it don't make sense no no because no
because I think you're a good case I
think you're a good case study I think
you're a woman no no I think I think a
woman that you said you know for 10
years you've been out the game
necessarily
um you know when we've spoken to you
what you want you want to you want a
complete family unit probably based on
some of the things that you've
experienced you're 28 you don't have any
child like and you know you honest you
had you had Therapies so you understand
some of the things you've gone through
you you're a candidate now for for a
good man but you need to listen to some
of the things that I've said so when
this good man comes you don't scare him
away with saying stuff like I won't
listen to you you know what I mean I
never said no but but what I'm trying to
say to you is this if you explained it
the way that you did afterwards about
like how men would feel when it comes to
women going out to the club like you
made it seem a little bit more different
I didn't I didn't I personally wasn't
looking at it the way that you explained
it like you you she he said it in more
in a secure way like it made it seem a
little bit more like okay I can
understand your point of view before it
was just like blunt like if I said you
can't go you can't go like oh well I
don't know you're talking to you
I didn't say it like that I didn't say
no but it came across that way to me yes
well well if you know for the for the
modern women out there that want to
learn to be wives and we're opening a
wife's School we're gonna bring in wives
from all over to teach teach modern
women how to cook clean
dancing and [ __ ] why cooking I clean can
I see a question though yeah so you got
this guy in America right let's say you
were to be out wherever and you met a
guy that was you know ticked all your
boxes and he was serious about trying to
get to know you
would you say no to him for the goddess
in America I've gone through that and
I've come right back to square one I've
done I've done that so somebody that I
saw as a potential so me as a potential
wanted to move forward
I don't know what happened but it didn't
go the way I wanted it to go to or the
way that he said it was going to go to
so I just left it for what it was and
then I rekindled what I have now going
on right now so was he a bad boy what
the guy that I used to talk about yeah
the one the one over here no he was a
good boy
um he was he was actually a good boy
yeah but I told her already with this
situation that she has over there I told
her
wait without waiting yeah like if that's
what you're gonna do then that's what
you're gonna do but don't wait yeah see
I want better results for for men I'm a
man so I want better results for us but
I want better results for women so this
thing when I said to you about yo what
Champion for women like it sounds mad
because men haven't spoken like this but
we have to get the backlash on the corn
for it we have to get people chopping us
up and making edits and trying to make
it change the narrative we have to get
this we have to get our colleagues that
said oh my God I see oh your views are
so misogyny we have to get all of this
but the reason we get this because it's
that vitally important for us to get
this message across there's so many men
that don't have a voice there's so many
men that are scared to speak and more
importantly women are scared to speak so
since I've come on this my third time
I've been on here I did not think it
would cause as many Ruffles as it has
right but I understand why but what we
need I get so many women in my DMs that
call me that message me that's even in a
few in the comments that support what
we're doing but the problem is there's a
minority of of women that are speaking
for the majority and this minority is
loud and they are rude and they are
crude and they represent and they are
now their voices represent in the larger
um the law they've also represented for
the majority right so when we speak and
then it doesn't sound in the beginning
we maybe bump our heads a little bit but
we actually come to a place of where you
understand that actually you know what I
didn't think of it like this my mind's
got a point that's the point we need
women to to Jump by us and be like right
okay cool these guys are actually trying
to help people get better results
because by you understanding now or
automatically I know you're going to get
better results you're going to look at
yourself you're going to look at your
time you're going to think to yourself
it's all how you say it too because like
like I said the beginning from where we
was that's not what you sounded like to
where we are right now I feel like if
you sit down and talk to me I will
listen if I feel like you're demanding
me and I don't understand what you're
saying to me I'm gonna be a bit like who
are you talking to you know no but it
was a hypothetical situation though
wasn't it because it came down to your
friendship with um with your friend
Aaron you were kind of just like no I
wouldn't listen so I guess we were just
giving how a man would perceive that but
I know what I mean I also think you're
asking a men to communicate like women
and so and so you're asking men are very
blunt and they're very direct and
they're not really trying to think about
your feelings and be considered unless
they're more feminine typically well
then and so and so when you say like you
need to communicate to me this way
you're basically saying be more like a
woman I don't feel like I'm saying that
I feel I don't think you mean to no I
don't feel like I'm saying that I feel
like I'm I don't think it's a problem
for anybody to be very
open and explain thoroughly about what
they're talking about because why is it
that you say JUMP I must I must jump
because men don't have the time to
explain every single decision that they
make and so it's like exhausting to them
so if you if he says hey can you do this
and you say why and then he has to have
a 10-minute conversation with you for
you to agree with it and now and now
you'll do it it's like that's exhausting
to a guy they would rather just have a
guy a girl that just says okay it's
because at that point I'm not that
though at that point
yeah it goes back to what we're saying
about a woman who a girlfriend a wife
who won't listen is really a big turn
off to a guy I feel like and it's
another podcast like it's cool I mean it
gives me content it's cool I'm not I'm
not complaining but like in a day-to-day
relationship like that's exhausting to
men they don't they don't men don't like
to sit around and talk to us I feel like
I'll be the voice for women that can
actually say if you speak to me where I
understand then I can listen if you're
demanding me from somebody who doesn't
have a father figure in her life like
that you have to understand how to treat
certain women not every woman is going
to be the same and not every man is
going to be the same what outcomes are
you looking for there
um what outcome yeah understand it no
but in terms of relationships what are
you looking for like do you want to be
married do you want a long time
relationship I would love to I would
like to be married I'm not going to
pinpoint and just say like I'm going to
be married tomorrow if it doesn't happen
it doesn't happen but I feel like my
main source or what I'm looking for is
true happiness and peace
irrespectively whether that's a
relationship because the reason I'm in a
relationship so in a relationship like
you were saying and I agree men tend to
be The Gatekeepers and the decision
makers as to whether something goes to a
relationship or a marriage so if you're
not behaving so what you'll do you'll
setting the criteria saying a guy has to
explain this to a certain way but as far
as relationships and marriage is
concerned you're not in a position to
lay out that criteria it's the guide
that's laying out the criteria and
saying listen
I expect my girlfriend if she trusts me
and she wants to be with me to listen to
what I'm saying it doesn't mean she
doesn't have a voice but ultimately if I
have something to say I can't I haven't
got time to be drawing her a diagram and
giving all these long-winded
explanations if she's not willing to
listen to me she hasn't really selected
me as her man and and another thing like
when you say like what are you looking
for like relationships and marriage it's
not about happiness it's about Duty and
so when a guy when a guy hears and I'm
just telling you this is just from a
guy's point of view like when they hear
like what do you want out of a
relationship and they say happiness
that's a red flag because your happiness
can come and go and it's like if you're
not happy tomorrow you're gonna leave
and the number one thing that men look
for is loyalty and so if you're not like
to that that says to a guy like I'll
leave if I'm not happy
and and that with with all the risk that
men have to take today in order to get
married it's it's like you know we're
asking them to do this but we give them
red flags along the way and this is
where there's not a lot of marriage is
going on there's less marriages in
comparison to our parents generation
feminine feminism sorry has given women
an unrealistic expectation of what of
what relationships and marriage really
are you know I I genuinely believe that
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible